>>I have a very deep belief now that-
that students do not do well
academically unless they feel cared
about, unless they feel that
they're included, unless they feel
that there's a climate around
them where they can take risks,
where they can share their learning,
share their, sometimes misconceptions
or wrong answers even and
test those out in the world
and not feel embarrassed
or put down by it.
So when you create that
kind of safe place,
students are better able to learn.
They're better able
to work with peers.
They're- they're more
comfortable in the classroom.
And- and there is a process that
we can consciously create both
through curriculum and-- set
curriculum and through our--
the way we structure our
classrooms that enables students
to feel that sense of community.
Over a period of the- the first
year, we developed the Care
for Kids Program and then had
schools apply for that program.
As I said, out of 90 schools,
28-- there are more that applied.
We accepted 28 schools
who appeared to be ready
to launch the program
the following year.
And then we provided extensive
professional development
for them during the summer and
embedded professional development
for them as they implemented
the program during the year.
And it made- it's made
a major difference.
Everywhere I go, when I talk
to elementary faculties,
it's made a major difference.
But those early initiators
in this case,
have provoked interest
among all the other schools.
As I said, this is an initiative
that people are eager for.
You know, one of the things-- and
it's very clear, is that teachers are
in teaching, particularly elementary
teachers, because they love kids.
And they love to create an
environment where kids can thrive.
And this is so natural.
They understand it at
a very basic level,
that if they create a positive
environment in their classroom,
their classroom is going to be
fun to be in both for themselves
and for them- for their students.
And the students are
gonna learn more.
And so it doesn't take
a lot of convincing.
It- it-- what it takes is the
demonstration that it can be done.
And when teaches see that it can be
done and that it can be successful,
then they're really willing to devote
the energy and time to make it work.
I believe that actually what
we're doing is going very deeply
and it's not about charismatic
principals or charismatic teachers.
It's about engaging all teachers and
all the principals in the strategies
that Care For Kids is engaged in.
And it shouldn't matter
who the principal is.
It's nice that the
principal is an advocate
and the principal believes
it and has to understand it.
We have to have principal
leadership but we don't have
to have charismatic
principal leadership.
We have to have principal leadership
that's committed to this kind
of vision and this direction.
And we have to have teachers who
are committed to this kind of vision
and this kind of direction.
And that's what we're pursuing in
our hiring and in our appointments.
We have a- a district
philosophy and that-
that district philosophy is
part of our interview process.
It's part of our selection process.
And hopefully, it won't be
dependent on one individual.
It will be dependent on a lot
of us being deeply committed
to the same kind of values and
norms and wanting to build a vision
of the district where-
where this is the norm.
Once you've done it,
you realize that--
or once you've been involved
in social emotional learning,
it changes the way you teach.
It changes the way you
are in a classroom.
It changes the interaction you
have with students so that you-
you don't have the kinds
of discipline problems
you've had before.
You don't have the kinds
of- of organizational issues
in the classroom that
you my have had before.
And what- what's so interesting is,
in giving up some of your authority
to students, which is sometimes
very difficult for teachers,
you realize that you
actually have more authority.
And it's one of those
paradoxes in life,
that when you literally involve
students in class meetings,
when you involve them in these
morning meetings and discussions
and sharing, that actually,
you giving up control,
allows you to have even more control
and more direction of the classroom,
because it's more of
a collective focus.
And students buy-in.
And once they buy-in, they're
a part of the classroom
and they're committed
to what you're doing.
Why doesn't everybody do it?
Well first of all, there are
probably two major reasons,
one is that we're very tied up in
the struggle to reach proficiency.
With No Child Left Behind, with
the targets that have been set,
I think most educators are in a
panic to attempt to do all they can
to prepare students academically
for the test and test results.
I happen to believe that this is
the best preparation for test-
for positive test results.
I think once you teach students
those kinds of social skills,
once they build a sense of community,
you can move much faster academically
than you would otherwise.
You have far fewer behavior
problems, far fewer disruptions,
far more collaboration on learning
so that students support each
other learn-- each others learning.
But it takes investment
of time on the front end.
And sometimes we're not willing
to devote that- that time.
The other is, it takes skill
to lead a class meeting.
An effective class meeting takes the
ability to not intervene too soon,
to not impose one's own values and
one's own thoughts on the situation
and let students engage and discuss
and struggle for a while and think
about a situation carefully and think
about what might be right or wrong
in a situation and what are different
possibilities and different options.
As teachers we tend
to want to jump in
and solve problems for our students.
And it means holding back and
letting the students emerge
with what are the best solutions
and facilitating that dialog.
And that's often much more
challenging for us to do.
It isn't touchy-feely stuff.
It's core social skills that
give students the- the experience
and the knowledge and talent to
work effectively with others.
This isn't about, you know, being
nice and treating each other nicely.
This is about, this is serious work.
It's serious work to
create a sense of community.
resolve conflicts.
It's serious work to create an
environment that's a positive
environment in a classroom.
And it's serious work
on the students' part,
to be able to manage themselves
in a way that is constructive.
And that's the most important
contribution that they learned.
I would say that it's essential for
higher quality results, academically.
And it's not that you don't
have to do the academic work.
You have to do the academic work.
But frankly, the academic work
is made easier once you do this
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org